et créé les conditions pour une ère
où informations et idées sont partagées librement.
Mais ces prouesses sont-elles le signe que nous avons atteint
notre limite en termes d'innovation technologique ?
Je ne pense pas.
Aujourd'hui, j'aimerais vous partager
comment, pour moi, le numérique nous amènera encore plus loin.
Je suis chirurgienne de profession,
et aujourd'hui, alors que je vous parle,
cinq milliards de personnes dans le monde n'ont pas accès aux soins chirurgicaux.
Cinq milliards de personnes.
C'est-à-dire que 70 % de la population mondiale,
selon la dernière commission Lancet de l'OMS,
ne peut même pas accéder à de simples soins chirurgicaux
quand elle en a besoin.
Regardons par exemple le Sierra Leone,
un pays de six millions d'habitants,
qui ne compte que 10 chirurgiens qualifiés selon une étude récente.
C'est-à-dire un chirurgien pour 600 000 habitants.
Ces chiffres sont vertigineux.
Mais pas besoin de regarder si loin.
Ici, aux États-Unis, une étude récente
indique que un besoin de 100 000 nouveaux chirurgiens d'ici 2030,
rien que pour répondre à la demande d'interventions de routine.
Au rythme où nous allons, nous n'atteindrons pas ce chiffre.
Comme chirurgienne, ce problème mondial m'inquiète.
Il m'inquiète beaucoup,
car j'ai été témoin de
comment le manque d'accès à des soins sûrs et abordables
peut briser les vies de gens ordinaires.
Si un patient a besoin d'être opéré
et qu'aucun chirurgien n'est disponible,
on se retrouve face à un choix cornélien :
attendre, se déplacer
ou ne pas se faire opérer du tout.
Quelle est la solution ?
Eh bien ,certains d'entres vous ont la solution sur eux aujourd'hui :
un smartphone, une tablette, un ordinateur.
Car pour moi,
les technologies numériques sont bien plus que des outils de communication
nous permettant d'acheter en ligne,
de se connecter aux réseaux sociaux et de se tenir informés.
Elles peuvent nous aider à résoudre certains problèmes importants
comme le manque d'accès à des services essentiels de chirurgie.
Aujourd'hui, j'aimerais partager
un exemple de comment rendre cela possible selon moi.
L'histoire de la chirurgie est pleine de d'avancées
où la science et la technologie ont aidé les chirurgiens à relever
leurs plus grands défis.
Il y a plusieurs siècles,
la maîtrise de la microbiologie
a mené au développement de techniques d'antisepsie
qui ont grandement contribué
à la survie post-opératoire des patients.
Des siècles plus tard,
la chirurgie laparo ou arthroscopique se développe,
qui combine technologie vidéo et instruments de précision
pour rendre la chirurgie moins invasive.
Beaucoup d'entre vous connaissent la chirurgie robotique, plus récente,
et la robotique donne à la chirurgie l'apport de systèmes modernes automatisés,
leur ultraprécision,
la possibilité d'opérer à une échelle microscopique
avec une précision qui dépasse même celle de la main humaine.
Mais la chirurgie robotique a aussi introduit autre chose dans la chirurgie :
l'idée qu'un chirurgien
n'a pas forcément besoin d'être au chevet du patient pour opérer
et qu'il peut regarder un écran
et piloter un robot à l'aide d'un ordinateur.
On appelle ça la téléchirurgie.
C'est notre responsabilité
de trouver des solutions bon marché et extensibles,
pour que chacun, peu importe où il se trouve dans le monde,
puisse avoir accès à ces solutions.
Et si je vous disais
qu'on n'a pas besoin d'un robot à un million de dollars
pour faire de la téléchirurgie ?
Et que tout ce qu'il faut est un téléphone, une tablette ou un ordinateur,
une connexion internet,
un collègue de confiance sur place
et un ingrédient magique :
un logiciel collaboratif de réalité augmentée.
En utilisant ce logiciel de réalité augmentée,
un chirurgien spécialiste peut donc se transporter virtuellement
dans n'importe quel cadre clinique
en utilisant simplement son téléphone, sa tablette ou son ordinateur
et interagir visuellement et concrètement dans une opération
du début à la fin,
guidant et encadrant l'intervention du médecin sur place étape par étape.
Bon, j'ai assez parlé.
Passons à la démonstration.
On va maintenant se connecter avec le Dr Marc Tompkins,
chirurgien orthopédique à l'Université du Minnesota.
Il va réaliser une arthroscopie pour nous,
une laparoscopie du genou,
et j'aimerais souligner
que ce patient a consenti à ce que son opération soit diffusée.
J'aimerais aussi souligner que, pour gagner du temps,
nous ne verrons que les premières étapes,
le marquage du patient
et l'identification de quelques repères anatomiques importants.
Allô, Dr Tompkins, vous m'entendez ?
Marc Tompkins : Bonjour Nadine.
Nadine Hachach-Haram : Un grand boujour de TED.
Public : Bonjour.
NHH : Bon, Dr Tompkins, allons-y.
Commençons par nos incisions et leurs emplacements
de chaque côté du tendon rotulien.
Si vous faites vos incisions ici et là,
nous devrions arriver à l'intérieur du genou.
MT : Ok, j'y vais.
NHH : Parfait.
Nous venons juste d'entrer dans l'articulation.
Jetons donc un coup d'oeil rapide au ménisque.
MT : Parfait.
NHH : Parfait, on peut voir qu'il y a une petite déchirure sur le ménisque
mais que sinon tout semble ok.
Pouvez-vous vous tourner dans cette direction,
suivez mon doigt.
Jetons un coup d'œil aux ligaments croisés.
L'antérieur semble en bon état,
pas de problème ici.
Donc nous venons d'identifier une petite déchirure ici,
mais à part ça, le liquide articulaire semble correct.
Ok, merci beaucoup, Dr Tompkins. Merci pour votre temps.
Je vais vous laisser continuer.
Bonne journée. Au revoir.
(Applaudissements)
J'espère que cette simple démonstration
a pu vous montrer à quel point la technologie peut être puissante.
Et je souligne que je n'ai pas utilisé d'équipement spécialisé,
juste mon ordinateur et une simple webcam.
On est habitué à utiliser le numérique
pour communiquer à l'oral, par texte et vidéo,
mais la réalité augmentée nous permet d'aller beaucoup plus loin.
Elle nous permet d’interagir virtuellement
en imitant la manière dont on collaborerait en personne.
Pouvoir montrer ce qu'on veut faire,
l'illustrer, le présenter et le mimer,
c'est tellement plus fort que de simplement le dire.
Et c'est un super outil de formation,
car on apprend mieux avec une expérience directe.
En quoi ceci nous permet-il de changer le monde ?
Quand à l'hôpital où j'enseigne,
nous utilisons cette méthode pour aider les hôpitaux locaux
dans les chirurgies du cancer de la peau et en traumatologie.
Désormais, les patients ont accès à des soins localement.
Leur temps de transport est réduit, leur accès amélioré,
et on sauve de l'argent.
On l'utilise depuis peu dans la gestion des plaies avec le personnel infirmier
et dans la médecine ambulatoire.
Récemment, elle a été employée
pour aider un chirurgien dans l'extraction d'une tumeur rénale.
J'aimerais juste vous montrer une courte vidéo à ce sujet.
Je m'excuse pour les images difficiles à regarder.
(Vidéo) Médecin 1 : Ok, remontrez-moi ça.
Médecin 2 : Si vous regardez ici,
vous voyez la partie supérieure, la plus exposée de la tumeur.
Médecin 1 : Oui.
Médecin 2 : Elle fait 3 cm de profondeur,
donc ceci devrait faire 3 cm.
M1 : Oui, oui.
M2 : Ok, il faut une marge de 3,5 cm.
M1 : Je vous montre quand même,
et vous me dites ce que vous en pensez.
NHH : On voit aussi cette technologie employée au niveau mondial.
Une des histoires les plus touchantes dont je me souvienne
s'est passée à Trujillo, une ville au nord de Lima au Pérou,
quand cette technologie a permis
d'opérer le bec-de-lièvre d'enfants
issus de milieux pauvres qui n'avaient pas accès à une assurance maladie.
Dans cette ville, il y avait un hôpital avec un chirurgien
travaillant dur pour offrir ces soins,
le Dr Soraya.
Elle avait du mal à répondre à la forte demande
de la population locale,
d'autant qu'elle n'avait pas reçu de formation propre à cette opération.
Mais avec l'aide d'une association,
nous avons pu lui présenter un chirurgien spécialiste en Californie,
et grâce à la téléchirurgie, il l'a guidée, ainsi que ses collègues,
à travers les étapes de l'opération
en les guidant et formant, en leur enseignant.
En quelques mois,
ils ont réalisé 30 % d'opérations en plus
avec de moins en moins de complications.
Et désormais, le Dr Soraya et son équipe peuvent opérer
de manière autonome, avec compétence et assurance.
Je me souviens d'une mère qui a dit :
« Cette technologie a donné son sourire à ma fille. »
Pour moi, voici le vrai pouvoir de cette technologie.
Sa beauté, c'est qu'elle abolit les frontières.
Elle surmonte toute difficulté technologique.
Elle connecte les gens. Elle démocratise l'accès.
La technologie sans fil et mobile augmente vite,
et devrait contribuer à la hausse des prestations chirurgicales.
On l'a même utilisée en zone de conflit où le risque de faire venir
des chirurgiens spécialistes est considérable.
Dans un monde où il y a plus d'appareils mobiles
que d'êtres humains,
cette technologie a vraiment une portée mondiale.
Bien sûr, on est encore loin
de pouvoir garantir l'accès à la chirurgie à 5 milliards de personnes,
et malheureusement,
certains n'ont toujours pas accès à Internet.
Mais les choses bougent vite et dans la bonne direction.
La possibilité de changer existe.
Mon équipe et moi augmentons notre présence dans le monde
et nous commençons à voir le potentiel de cette technologie.
Grâce au numérique,
grâce à des outils simples et ordinaires que nous tenons pour acquis,
grâce à des appareils du futur,
nous pouvons vraiment faire des miracles.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)